on friday the biden regime held its
first cabinet meeting since july and the
question is why
what is the point of this cabinet what
good do they do
last week we noted how refreshing it was
to see elected leaders like glenn yonkin
and when some sears be positive and
practical the feel good factor instead
of the democrats non-stop moralizing and
patronizing
virtue signaling and dividing these
republican winners talk about solving
real problems trump did that of course
the best economy in history taxes down
regulation down jobs up earnings up blue
collar boom securing the border standing
up to china rebuilding the military
independence and energy he even solved
problems he didn't promise to with trump
thanks to the natural gas revolution
america's carbon emissions fell to the
lowest level in 30 years tell that to
the green new deal climate zealots
but under biden it's not just that
they're not solving problems it's much
worse
let's examine the life cycle of a
problem in this omni shambles
that is the biden regime
stage one create the problem
so when you inherit a growing economy
make sure you overheat it with a 1.9
trillion dollar spending spree
every time you see rising prices
remember it's not some natural disaster
it was created by biden and the
democrats with that first giant spending
bill in march who says that democrats
obama economic advisor jason furman
described biden's rescue plan as quote
the original sin
and here is clinton's treasury secretary
just this week
they're just not recognizing
just how much demand
is being created
by the tremendous wall of money
15
of gdp
in
one year
that
they released uh
last
spring what we infused was very very was
very very large and it was kind of
predictable that it would lead to
uh excess demand and inflation there was
never a macroeconomic analysis
demonstrating that this was an
appropriate plan it came out of a whole
range of political political uh
machinations
and then to really help with the
inflation crisis you've created why not
create an energy crisis what better way
to make the price of everything go up
than by raising the cost of energy which
is a key component of industry so cancel
pipelines ban natural gas close down
nuclear power energy supply goes down
the price goes up and you hit working
americans hard five dollar gas winter
fuel up 50 that'll show them
but it's okay because you just send
people money for months on end which of
course helps you create a supply chain
crisis as people stay home and
businesses can't find workers so they
raise their wages which means their
costs go up which means they have to put
their prices up which is all great for
the biden problem creators because that
pushes inflation even higher
and once you've created the problems you
move to biden omni shambles stage two
deny and dismiss the exact problems you
created
there's no energy crisis are you kidding
what is the grand home plan to increase
oil production in america
oh my god
that is hilarious wood that i had the
magic wand on this is
inflation no that's not a thing and even
if it is a thing it's only temporary
it's transitory
transitory impact on prices transitory
effects transitory impacts their
expectation is that these inflation
rises will be transitory just gonna pop
up a little bit and then go back down
just pop up a little bit and that's okay
they say because wages are going up too
and they're right wages are going up
only problem is
inflation is going up faster
of course there's no supply chain crisis
you just need to what was it lower your
expectations and the reason you can't
find anything in the stores is because
the economy is actually doing great
the tragedy of the short the treadmill
that's delayed there are a thousand
points in that chain where something can
go wrong and we're seeing a lot of those
points reveal themselves because of the
enormous demand
enormous demand it's all going so well
and even if there was a supply chain
crisis they can't actually tell you what
they're doing about it
so i don't have the specifics for you
right now it's going to be broken down
into agencies the specifics on that i
don't have to share with you today
what they can share is that there's no
problem with businesses not being able
to find workers they just need to pay
more
in some places it may be that you have
to pay more wages in order to attract
workers
thanks jen any other advice i'm sure
we're all ears considering you and the
rest of the omnishambles crew have never
created a job in your entire lives now
once you've finished denying and
dismissing the problems you created you
can move to biden omni shambles stage
three
make the problems worse
so make the energy crisis worse by
closing down even more pipelines even
better close down american energy
businesses
here what i'm thinking about is
primarily coal industry and oil and gas
industry a lot of the smaller players in
that industry are
uh going to probably uh go bankrupt in
in in short order at least we want them
to go bankrupt if we want to tackle
climate change right
right
make the inflation crisis worse by
pushing ahead with your mad federal
government centralization scheme to
spend even more trillions of dollars
then make the supply chain crisis worse
with your plan to solve it yes indeed
since biden announced his plan to unjam
the ports a month ago guess what
the ports have gotten more jammed with
more delays and more backlogs honestly
it takes real skill to be this
incompetent this unserious
and then to cover up the fact that your
actual supply chain solution is making
the problem worse you desperately try to
claim that your infrastructure bill
which will only start to be implemented
the year after next if you're lucky
we'll get things moving next week except
don't tell your transportation secretary
who's come up with a new way of saying
that no actually we're not really
talking about shovel ready projects
emphasis is going to be on shovel worthy
projects some of which are ready to go
immediately
shuffle worthy that's going to get the
ports unjammed is it shovel worthy where
do they get these people oh mckinsey
yeah that would explain it
and don't forget you can also make the
supply chain crisis worse by firing
unvaccinated workers and while you're at
it fire border patrol agents for being
unvaccinated while creating new
financial incentives for unvaccinated
illegal immigrants to enter the country
so you can make the border crisis that
you created worse come to think of it
that would also help make the economic
crisis worse by importing more cheap
labor so american workers can continue
to stay at home and get the ever higher
welfare checks you're planning to send
them brilliant you see it all makes
sense
and actually
we were told about the biden omni
shambles we just didn't listen
forget about poor naive democrat
congresswoman abigail spamberger and her
pithy observation that biden was not
elected to be fdr he was elected to be
normal and stop the chaos that's what
she thought
the person who knew biden best knew
different
obama he did warn us
never
underestimate joe's ability to f things
up
how right he was
i'm steve ducey i'm brian kilmeade and
i'm ainsley earhardt and click here to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis